[Music]
Kajal you're 16 today physically you're
still 15 oh I remember
Sixteen Candles is the movie that shot
Molly Ringwald to fame she was the face
of teens with a yes it was the pout
that's what she nailed all the time yeah
but that was a long time ago now Molly's
playing the mom role in Riverdale the TV
series based on the classic Archie comic
hi Eddie
I loved Archie growing up I was always
really interested in you know a mime or
Betty and mime or Veronica what am I
gonna be like when I grow up Who am I
and then it turns out I'm Archie's mom
in the series Molly had left hubby Luke
Perry and their son Archie played by KJ
app'
it's okay but she's back in town Molly
now 49 doesn't look a whole lot older
than when we first met her at 15 a
founding member of the 80s brat pack
giving us her advice for teen wannabes I
tell them it's a lot of fun it's hard
work you have to be very mentally stable
and have a good family background but
now surrounded by young actors on
Riverdale she's keeping any guidance to
herself I really make a point of not
giving advice I try with my own kids it
never works I mean people really need to
kind of figure out their own path the
most I could say is is you know wear
sunscreen with her husband writer honey
oat gianopolous
Molly has three kids it's just a matter
of time when they'll be the age molly
was when she suffered through those teen
years in one hit film after another
well my elder daughter Matilda is almost
14 and she has seen them all
the other two or just seven so
apparently they did see sixteen Candles
at a slumber party which I didn't sign
off on
[Music]
you